Let us look a little bit at the scaling of
one electrical,
one piece of electrical apparatus.
I don't want to spend a great deal of time
but a little time we can spend on this.
Let us look a little bit at resistance measures
as a function of scale.
I want to remind you of how resistance works
with scale.
This simple operation of resistors. Here we
have these two electrodes,
and I think we have a couple of people who
are going to work the circuits for us.
Could we have a couple of volunteer circuits?
Thank you very much.
It is worthwhile first bringing the two electrodes
together
to show people what zero resistance looks
like on the meter.
Can you do that? Just touch them.
And there the meter, way of here, shows zero
resistance,
and now pull them apart but don't touch them.
Now then they're way over at the other end,
that's almost an infinite resistance,
nothing but the air and the dry wood between
them.
So here is zero resistance, here is a very
high resistance.
Now let's measure your circuit resistance
if we can.
You'll want to wet your hands, I think it'll
help the contact
because it will make contact more uniform
if the hands are always wet.
There's no, or only a tiny battery here, there's
no danger of any kind.
I turn the scale.
And therefore it's about, I read about four
on this scale
which is a good place to read it.
Now let's try you.
Very good.
And again, not very different, about three.
Slightly larger hands I believe and that makes
the difference.
Now that's three and four. Suppose we make
the circuit go all the way through,
what would you expect to get? The circuit
is being lengthened.
So I think you'll add, first the one resistance
and then the other.
These people are in series.
Of course there's also a little extra contact
resistance
and the result indeed is about six or seven.
That's very good. That's similar to the sum.
On the other hand let's make the two circuits.
You will allow the circuit to travel, OK?
And then you help her.
See? Now the circuit is going through both
at once. Each one is helping.
The circuit has been widened instead of lengthened
if you like and now the result is less than
either one.
It's well under two, as you see here on the
meter.
Thank you very much.
Good circuitry.
So we see that the circuit works in that fashion.
And now let me just describe the scaling a
little bit.
So we get some numbers down.
It's clear if I have a piece of wire like
that or a piece of wire like that.
This is shorter than this.
This resistance should be greater than this
resistance.
So the resistance, in ohms say, is proportional
to the length of the circuit L.
And if I double the length I would expect
to double the resistance,
holding everything else equal.
That's what we learned from the series connection.
But what about the other connection which
people call shunt or parallel?
Where both circuits work at once.
That corresponds to putting another line here,
to widening it.
And of course if I make it in proportion wider,
twice wider,
I'd expect to get less resistance due to having
more available.
And the less comes both because making it
wider this way,
and also in three dimensions, making it wider
going in and out of the board.
So two powers of L come from that.
And that part goes like L squared.
So the overall result is like one over L.
The resistance, two similar resistors, will
have resistance
in the proportion one over their characteristic
size, a typical size.
So a big resistor, a big piece of wire will
have a much smaller resistance
than a small piece of similar wire made by
one power of the size ratio.